today I'm going to be showing you how to
program a new smart key to a Hyundai
this is a Hyundai Veloster 2013 model at
present there is one existing working
key for the car will lock and unlock the
vehicle we have our new smart key which
is not yet programmed so it will not
work now there is a few important things
to note before you start this process
first thing you need to note is you will
need the pin code to program new keys
there is a separate video showing you
how to do this how to read the pin code
with the handy baby please ensure you
have that code before proceeding you
will also need to program in existing
keys at the same time please make sure
you have all keys to be programmed as
long as you have followed those two
steps you're okay to proceed we want to
plug in the OBD cable into the OBD port
which is located to the right hand side
of the steering wheel in this car under
a panel that is labeled fuse and OVD
once you plug in you want to make sure
you have two lights power and bluetooth
on your VCR interface you're going to
grab your obd star and agree to the
disclaimer click on diag program make
sure you select immobilizer go across to
hyundai click ok on the latest version
you want to go to select from vehicle
Australia scroll down until you find
Veloster 2012 onwards press ok smart key
system press ok you want to select
program smart keys says please press the
start button so you grab your existing
key press the start button twice until
it goes to the on position hit OK switch
ignition off so press the start button
once more to turn the ignition off press
ok it then asks you to input your
security code which we have already
noted for this vehicle it will then ask
you to confirm you have inputted the
correct code please make sure you have
this is very important as long as you
have done this correctly you will need
to prepare for the next step as you only
have a limited time to proceed you need
to grab your existing smart key it will
ask you to contact the start button and
then press the start button for five
seconds so you want to grab your smart
key and just hover it over the start
button and press ok then you want to
push the start button in as soon as you
get that message now says program
success whether to program next one so
we're going to take away our existing
key and grab the new one now for this
one hold the start button down before
pressing yes press yes release start
button and press again you will get a
message that says program success press
ok it asks you to confirm the keys our
program so press ok
unplug the cable from the OBD port
and test keys so existing key locks and
unlocks the vehicle new key locks and
unlocks the vehicle will do one final
test new key press the start button and
it turns on the ignition thanks everyone